One idea you'll run across with transparent textures is that of premultiplied
alpha. PMG files never used premultiplied alpha. Other formats vary. Texture
data can be stored however you want in memory, either unmultiplied or
premultiplied. So what's it mean? Here's the blending equation normally used
for transparency. The source, that is the transparent object, is blended with
the destination, the object behind it using the source's alpha value.
Premultiplied alpha means just that. The term alpha source times color source
is going to be the same every time this texture data is accessed. We can
premultiply the original color by the alpha, and store this new color in
memory. This new equation saves a multiplication every single time this text
cell is accessed. Say we access this texture 60 times a second and a million
text cells are accessed. That saves 60 million multiplies a second, which could
start to add up.